échec colossal débacle honte absolue
comment l'armée la police et les
services de sécurité israéliens ont-ils
pu se laisser surprendre par l'attaque
massive du Hamas contre son territoire
depuis samedi cette question entre les
commentateurs militaires israéliens
l'État hébreux s'étaient réveillé dans
la stupéfaction générale le 7 octobre
dernier tandis que plus de 5000
roquettes volaient vers les villes
israéliennes près d'un millier de
Palestiniens enfonçaient la clôture
sécurisée réputée infranchissable qui
sépare Israël de la bande de Gaza mince
territoire côtier peuplé de Palestiniens
et contrôlé par le mouvement islamiste
du Hamas 3 jours plus tard plus de 700
morts et 2150 blessés israéliens sont à
déplorer selon l'armée plusieurs
dizaines de personnes dont de nombreux
civils ont été prises en otage par les
commandos palestiniens c'est de loin le
pire jour de l'histoire d'Israël jamais
auparavant autant d'Israéliens n'avaient
été tués en une seule fois cette vaste
opération armée baptisée déluge d'Al AXA
par la branche armée du Hamas
palestinien a vraisemblablement
nécessité plusieurs mois de préparatifs
or ces derniers semblent être passé
totalement inaperçu du chinbet le
service israélien chargé de la lutte
antiterroriste ainsi que des services de
Rense enseignement de l'armée comment
expliquer un tel manque d'anticipation
de la part de services réputés parmi les
plus efficaces au monde en Israël la
mémoire traumatisante de la guur du
Kipour qui a pris de cours les forces
armées du pays en 1973 est plus vivace
que jamais à l'époque les dirigeants
israéliens avaient totalement
sous-estimé les intentions de l'ennemi
la même erreur semble avoir été commise
cette fois-ci ce samedi 7 octobre comme
il y a 50 ans les responsables
israéliens pensaient que le Hamas
n'avait aucun projet de mener des
incursions terrestres d'envergure sur le
territoire israélien par crainte de
représaill massive dans la de Gaza en
outre Israël se croyait à l'abri
derrière la clôture de sécurité à 1
milliard de dollars érigé le long de la
frontière avec la bande de Gaza qui a
pourtant été enfoncé par l'armée
islamiste à l'aide de bulldozer et de
camionnettes enfin les espoirs
d'apaisement ont brouillé les
perceptions côté israélien en augmentant
de 18000 à 20000 le nombre de permis de
travail accordés à des Palestiniens de
la bande de Gaza Israël espérait
s'acheter la paix par l'argent une série
d'erreurs qui pousse aujourd'hui Israël
à se préparer à toutes les éventualités
tandis que le Hamas est sur le pied de
guerre et soutenu par l'Iran de nouveaux
fronts pourrai s'ouvrir au nord du pays
à la frontière avec le Liban et la
Syrie